PROFESSOR: Einstein's argument,
we consider again our atoms.
And this time we're going to
use the thermal equilibrium.
We're going to really
make use of that fact.
So, again, we have
level b and level a.
And this is Einstein's argument.
And we're going to
have no populations.
If we discuss equilibrium, we
can consider a system in a box.
And there's a few billion atoms.
And there's some
atoms whose electron
is going to be in state b.
Some atoms whose electrons
are going to be in state a.
Let's call these
numbers Nb and Na.
And we also have
photons at temperature T
and have a beta parameter 1 over
the Boltzmann constant times T.
So this is the process
we're going to consider.
So what's going to happen?
If we came up from the edition
that we've built from 806,
we would think,
OK, there's going
to be absorption process and
stimulated emission process.
And between the
two, they're going
to be able to reach equilibrium.
We don't believe this is not a
process that can equilibrate.
So this would be our intuition.
The intuition for
people that lived
at the beginning of last
century was rather different.
They felt that there would
be absorption process
and there was
spontaneous emission.
The thing that you probably
intuitively would think,
if you are at a high level,
you spontaneously decay.
So the thing that
was not known to them
was this stimulated emission.
That is what Einstein is
credited for discovering here.
People felt, and I think the
paper finds that makes clear
that the intuition,
is that you have
spontaneous emission,
in which spontaneously
by some kind of instability,
the higher state goes
to the bottom.
And you have absorption.
But then Einstein figured
out that you couldn't achieve
equilibrium in that way.
Well, the way we're
going to do it,
we're going to put the
two things we know--
the absorption
and the stimulated
emission-- and see
that we don't get it
to work, the equilibrium.
But then when we add the
spontaneous emission, we will.
And as it turns out,
the spontaneous emission
is a little harder to calculate.
If we were to do it
in 806, it probably
would be a matter of
two lectures involving
an electromagnetic field.
So we will not do it.
But the good thing is that
Einstein's argument tells you
the speed of spontaneous
emission, the rate
of spontaneous
emission, in terms
of this rate of stimulated
emission or absorption.
So it does the
calculation for you
by some other
thermodynamical means.
So we're going to
use here three facts.
One is that the--
three facts-- one is the
populations are in equilibrium.
So Na dot is they stop
changing is equal to 0.
And Nb dot is equal to 0.
They don't stop changing
because nothing happens.
All the time there
will be emission,
and there will be absorption.
But if you reach equilibrium,
the number of atoms
remain the same on every state.
So that's our statement
that the populations
achieve equilibrium.
The second statement is that the
equilibrium is thermodynamical.
So it's thermal equilibrium.
That is Nb over Na, for example,
is the Boltzmann factor e
to the minus beta, Eb over
e to the minus beta Ea.
And this is equal to e to the
minus beta h bar omega ba.
You get e to the minus
beta, eb minus ea.
But eb minus ea
is h bar omega ba.
So that's thermal equilibrium.
And the last thing
that we need is
a statement about the photons.
What do they do when
they have equilibrium?
And that was known already
due the work of Planck
and others, black
body equilibrium.
So we need to know something
about the thermal radiation.
And the way one describes
this is in terms of a function
U of omega d omega.
In the black body
radiation, there
are at a given
temperature, there
are photons with
very little energy.
There are some largest
number of photons
with some energy associated
with temperature,
and then it decays.
So you have photons
of all energy.
So if you want a description of
what's going on in black body
radiation, you can
consider the energy
in the photons in
the frequency range.
But you even must
be more precise.
It is the energy per unit
volume in a frequency range.
Because if it's different,
the energy of the black body
cavities, this room
or it's a little box.
So it's an energy per
volume per frequency range.
And that's what
this quantity is.
So let me write it.
Energy per unit volume in
the frequency range dw.
In other words, it's kind of a
proxy for the number of photons
available.
All the photos have at some
value of the frequency,
of energy e omega.
So if you know the
energy, you basically
are getting here the number of
photons with frequency omega
in that range per unit
volume, all that stuff.
So this has a formula.
And the formula that
was known to people
was this quantities and then
omega cube, d omega, over e
to the beta h bar omega minus 1.
So this is the basis
of the calculation.
What do we do?
We have to consider
the possible processes.
OK, so our processes
are absorption.
And in this case,
we go from a to b.
And let's try to
write a rate for them.
So what would the
rate depend on?
Well, here's some
little assumptions.
Certainly, if you don't have
particles in the a state,
you cannot have this process.
So this process, the total
rate that we observe in the box
will depend on an Na.
The more particles
you have in this state
a, the larger the probability
that you get the transitions,
and the larger the rate.
It will also be affected
by the number of photons
available at that
frequency that can
produce a transition in
proportional to that.
And finally, the quantity
that our study of perturbation
theory will tell us
about, but at that time,
finds that was not known, it's
a transition coefficient, Bab,
he called it.
And this is the unknown one.
And this is what we don't know.
We know U. We assume we know Na.
This is the transition
rate per atom
and then multiplied by
the number of atoms.
So this is transition
rate per atom.
Then we have the process
of spontaneous emission.
And then we will be
another coefficient, Bba.
And it would depend on
the number of particles
that are in the state b,
because spontaneous emissions
that transition from b to a.
We call it-- oh, not
spontaneous stimulated.
I'm sorry-- stimulated emission.
This is the one
we're considering.
It's stimulated
by the radiation.
So it's also proportional
to the number
of photons present
and proportional
to the number of
atoms that can be
convinced to do the transition
times another coefficient, Bba.
So this is, I think,
what we in 806 would do.
We would consider
this two processes
and attempt to make it work.
And let's see what we get then.
We're trying to get equilibrium.
So we want the transitions to
equilibrate and, therefore,
the populations not to change.
So let's look-- for example--
you could look at either one,
but you can look at Nb dot.
It should be 0.
But it's equal to the
rate of absorption
minus the rate of
stimulated emission.
You see because the
number of particles in b
change because you get
some new particles in state
b due to the absorption process.
And it happens with this rate.
And you lose some particle
because some atoms
do the transition from the
higher level to the lower
level.
So what is the
rate of absorption?
We have it here.
It's this one, Bab
U of omega ba Na.
And this one is Bba, the
same U of omega ba Nb.
And we can factor the U out.
And this is the wrong
calculation, I must say,
because we're missing
that extra process that
was intuitive to
Einstein, but to us it's
a little less clear--
Nb times U of omega ba.
OK, I can do a one
more little thing.
I can factor an Na.
And this becomes Bab minus Bba
to the minus beta h bar omega
Ba U of omega ba.
OK, I use the ratio of Na
over Nb being thermodynamical.
So Nb over Na was used
from point two to get this.
And this should be equal to 0.
But this equation
can't be satisfied.
What do you have here?
You should be able to
equilibrate at any temperature.
On the other hand,
what is our intuition
about these quantities,
Bab and Bba?
They should be
temperature independent.
These are properties of the
geometry of those states
and the overlaps of
the wave functions.
These are atomic
physics properties
of the levels of the particles.
We will calculate them.
And here is the input of
how many photons there
are, how many atoms there are.
And the number of
photons certainly
depend on the temperature.
The number of atoms
for equilibrium
depend on the temperature.
But this is a factor
that says, well,
how likely is the transition
once you have a photon
and once you have an atom?
And that depends like we did
for the ionization, calculated
some matrix elements
that are totally
independent of temperature.
So these numbers are totally
And we're asking
this to be 0, which
requires this factor to be 0.
And this depends on temperature.
So you cannot attain
equilibrium with this way.
So it's impossible to satisfy
for all temperatures given
that Bab and Bba are constants.
So we're missing a process.
This is the process that
Einstein thought was intuitive,
the process of
spontaneous emission.
So we add one more process.
It's called
spontaneous emission.
And it's a process
also from b to a.
And it's going to have a rate.
But it's not going
to depend, that rate,
on the number of photons,
because it's happening
independently of the photons.
So we don't have this U factor.
We do have the Nb because
each of the b atoms
can spontaneously decay.
But we don't have the U factor.
So what do we have?
A rate, which is the
term by a coefficient
that Einstein called it a,
that's why the name a and b
coefficients of
Einstein, a times and b.
So that's the
spontaneous emission rate
per atom multiplied by
the number of atoms.
So we go back to our equation--
rate of absorption minus
rate of stimulated emission
minus the rate of
spontaneous emission.
So I'll write it here.
0 is equal to Nb dot
equal minus A Nb--
that's the spontaneous emission.
We write it first.
And then we'll write
the other two--
Bba and Nb U omega ba
plus Bab U of omega ba Na.